great
textings
ladies and
to receive the gentlemen
of
good evening councillors ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to this meeting of
council
good evening
thank you
i'd like you to remain standing
before we before we finally start the
meeting i invite my chaplain father joel
murphy to saint anthony of padua
stratford to lead us in prayer at the
jed
and to come forward
in the name of the father and the son
and the holy spirit
as we gather
this evening
and mindful of the concerns of the
buddha we also bear in mind
our world and the need for peace
we pray for an end to all hatred for
reconciliation from all peoples
and for
the laying down of arms
and we ask this through christ our lord
amen
thank you father jed
please be seated everybody
apologies i have received apologies for
absence
from councillors dr carr chilton dagno
jarman lloyd minis mitchell proctor and
please note that councillor ryan has had
to give apologies because of the need to
self-isolate
can i ask if anyone is aware of any
other apologies
as we are here again at the live center
we do not have our normal
boating facilities so any votes this
evening
will be by show of hands
this meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meetings
youtube channel
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded where there are confident where
there are confidential items or exempt
items this activity
apologies for that the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
and this activity promotes democratic
engagement
in accordance with section 100a
of the local government's act
1972
also like on previous occasions when
speaking members have the option of
coming forward to the table up front or
if they prefer can make use of the
roaming mics
first item is the minutes and i moved
the minutes of the meeting held
on the 26th of january
2022 be taken and read as a record and
signed as a correct record
is that seconded secondly
all in favor
announcements does the leader of the
council wish to make any announcements
this evening no thanks chad
do the chairs of scrutiny have anything
to announce on behalf of their
committees
no thank you
item three
the main item this evening is the budget
and i am proposing to conduct the
business as we have done in previous
years
introducing the item councilor ross the
executive member for finance and
governance
will have a maximum of 15 minutes to
make the initial speech
and at the end
the leader of the council will have a
further
maximum of 15 minutes to bring the
debate to a close
on behalf of the main opposition
councillors morgan
will have a maximum of 15 minutes and
then councilman new grosh and councillor
jerome on behalf of the minority
opposition groups
will each have a maximum of 10 minutes
to make their initial speeches
during which they may give notice of any
amendments already submitted hope that's
clear to everybody
before the debate is brought to a close
councillors coggins new grush and then
councilor evans as leaders of the
opposition groups will each have a
further maximum of five minutes
immediately before the leader of the
council winds up the debate
therefore with those timings set aside
we will need to aim to conclude the main
debates on the budget by 8 30 pm just
ask everybody to
keep that in mind the main debate by 8
30
to allow the leaders to sum up we've got
a lot of business to get through this
evening
if there are any amendments they will be
dealt with in the order in which notice
is given and i will call on
these to be moved without further
comments
the seconder and all the speakers will
be limited to three minutes
debate on the main motion will also have
a maximum length of three minutes for
speeches
can i remind you that if necessary i may
have to reduce the time for speeches
and the number of speakers in order to
come complete the business
i also draw council's attention to
regulations that require votes on the
budget to be recorded
so how members cast their votes will be
recorded in the minutes do i have the
council's consent to proceed on this
basis chair may i make an observation
with regard to the intent to
curtail the budget discussion at 8 30.
by my estimation that would permit a
full hour for debate of a single motion
but would only allow 10 minutes of
unprotected time for members who are not
group leaders
combined to contribute to
the discussion
i'm concerned that i had
imagined that we may seek to wind up the
budget discussion around 9 pm to allow
40 minutes or so
for all members
to have the opportunity to contribute by
which i mean if we were to allow 15
minutes for councillor ross 15 minutes
for councillor morgan
10 minutes for councillor jerome 10
minutes to council of new grosh
15 minutes for myself
five minutes for the group leaders to
wind up
my estimation is that that takes us to
more or less
8 30 as things currently stand just shy
of that we would have had if we'd have
begun the debate immediately at seven
around 10 minutes i think we're now down
at about four
so it's a request for us to consider
only 30 minutes to debate a single
motion which is more than we would
normally afford a motion in full council
and therefore accept
accepting that members may wish to have
something substantive to sound the
budget thanks jeff
um
so that i understand it and a lot of
that went over my head from the leader
but more importantly to the members here
before i bring in council evans i think
what council western the lead is
proposing is that we don't curtail the
main debate at 8 13 he thinks we need to
give that debate substantial time and i
think the main debate concludes at nine
o'clock is that what you're saying
so
i am
concerned but i think i may have
misunderstood chair this is my fault are
you suggesting that we will have
from nine until 9 30 to debate the clean
air motion or are you suggesting that
all of the budget debate including my
contributions and that the group leaders
needs to be concluded by 8
no
no
and i will shut up because i've made an
idiot for myself apologies
so what i'm saying is that for the
members to contribute to the budget
debate i wanted that to be completed by
8 30. and i reckoned up 40 minutes for
the leaders to sum up including
a good self
leader so
is everybody clear is everybody
understanding i can see some
some mystified people
if if we could talk about a main debate
if i invite people to speak from the
flow if i call that the main debate ask
him that that is concluded by 8 30.
um the leaders of the liberal democrats
the green group conservatives and indeed
the leader
have stipulated time that they need to
use
to conclude the debate the leader has 15
minutes to sum up
i think the leader of the opposition has
15 minutes to sum up
and we need to give them time to do that
so is everybody understanding that and
if you don't please say so because
i want everyone to get it yeah we're
okay with that
so do i have councils consent to proceed
on this basis hi thank you
for the council are the executive
recommendations for the budget agreed at
the executive meeting earlier this
evening
including the updated precept figures
which have been circulated
these will be moved by the executive
member for finance and governance
councillor ross i invite you to open the
debate
thank you mayor
i'm very proud to present this labour
administration's fourth budget our
medium-term financial strategy treasury
management and capital strategies with a
slight amendment to the formal council
tax resolution under annex j
four years of robust financial
management in the face of economic and
political uncertainty has ensured that
we can invest millions of pounds in our
schools roads towns businesses social
care and leisure centres as well as
supporting our most vulnerable residents
this is a budget that looks to
trafford's future as we recover from the
covid19 pandemic
i believe local government continues to
be a force for good at a time where
faith in national politics seems to be
in free fall
and i want to take a few moments to pay
tribute to our council employees who
continue to go above and beyond and
demonstrate the very best of public
service
throughout 2122 our colleagues in social
care have supported our most vulnerable
residents and helped keep people safe
our team and children's services have
supported our younger population
including our youth engagement team and
our drop-in and street talk teams
our school catering and cleaning
services have provided meals and kept
settings clean despite many challenges
we continue to support the work of our
school crossing patrol officers and seek
new recruits
our team index checker services have
provided grants to businesses and
individuals in need of support and have
also moved to a cash-first approach
waterside arts centre trafford music
service and our libraries and local
studies team have promoted arts culture
and knowledge both virtually and in real
life
our licensing and public protection
teams have been making sure venues keep
safe and people have the confidence in
the private hire drivers we license
our housing options team continue to
assist people out of homelessness
against the context of an ongoing
housing crisis
star procurement continue to target
social value and drive up local spend
our registrars at sale town hall
continue to be there
for people at times of key life events
and our bereavement services team
support people as they lay their loved
ones to rest
in the meantime one trafford colleagues
continue to empty bins maintain our
green spaces and our highways
i'd also like to acknowledge the work
that continues to go on in the response
to covert 19
including the oversight provided by our
public health team our outbreak
management and contact tracing hub team
our testing team and community
engagement team
two years ago we couldn't have imagined
these roles would exist and it's a
tribute to our workforce that the
council responded so quickly and will
continue to adapt as the situation with
covid19 resolves revolves
i'm aware that this is just a flavor of
the work carried out across the council
but the point i wish to make is that
trafford council is nothing without its
workforce and i know we all remain
grateful for everything they do
we are determined that as we emerge out
of the pandemic the future should be
bright for everyone in trafford
residents businesses and communities
alike
during the past year the executive have
reviewed our corporate plan to ensure
that we meet the right policies in place
for the borough
we want to see all our residents have
access to quality learning training and
jobs we want all our communities to be
happy healthy and safe and we want all
our businesses and town centres to
recover and flourish
the outcomes we want are underpinned by
actions we need to take including
reducing health inequalities supporting
people out of poverty and addressing our
climate crisis
i believe that this set of budget
proposals align with our stated
ambitions
to this end the revenue budget choices
we have made include an additional
funding for children's adult social care
of over 10 million pounds and additional
investments support increases in the
fair price for care which includes
increases due to the national living
wage
we're also investing an additional 500
000 pounds in our leisure centres to
ensure the sustainability of these
crucial facilities
as part of the capital budget this year
we're proposing to make significant
advent investments across all areas of
the council
these include over 19 million pounds
investment in school infrastructure over
5 million pounds targeted support for
some of our most vulnerable residents
8.12 million as part of our leisure
strategy and sports facility provision
improvement
and provision of cycling and walking
routes amounted to over 3 million pounds
over 12 million pounds of investment
into major highways and other key
infrastructure improvements
four million pounds worth of investment
to open up trafford waters for
residential development
over 13 million pounds of investment as
part of the future high street fund
together with one and a half million
pounds investment in town center public
realm
investment in greenery initiatives
including the installation of
reservation cremators and the
improvement of green spaces and
biodiversity
and will also support businesses through
the option of town centre and business
loans
our asset investment strategy will align
with our corporate priorities and we
continue to take a prudent approach with
the investment management board open for
all parties to join plus independent
expert advice
the strategy will continue to support
acquisitions that age regeneration
projects in the borough
and over the last three years the
strategy has provided over 15 million
pounds to support our revenue budgets
and we're targeting that 7.56 million
pounds of income to support the 2223
budget
this budget also contains measures that
will support our carbon neutral action
plan first launched in december 2020
including our decarbonisation programme
the
ambitious set of budget proposals is
only possible because this
administration continues to present
robust budgets and react to financial
certainty
local government finance remains under
immense pressure and councils experience
a 15 billion times
pound real terms reduction to core
government funding between 20 2010 and
2020.
each council across the country has had
to address budget gaps since the onset
of austerity measures and from a traffic
perspective we have had to absorb a
total of
243.25 million
of cumulative expenditure pressures and
funding reductions between 2010 and
2021.
looking ahead we forecast a further
budget gap of 38.59
million pounds of which just over 20
million relates to this occurring budget
year
austerity of this scale pursued by the
coalition government was always going to
fail and we're still paying the price
for that policy over a decade later
in addition to this trafford remains in
a position where we received the lowest
funding per head of population across
all greater manchester authorities based
on core spending power
we have the lowest count lowest total
expenditure ahead of population across
all gm authorities and the fifth lowest
across all metropolitan boroughs
trafford also maintains the second
lowest council tax rate across all gm
authorities
if trafford did receive the same funding
ahead as its gm neighbors our finances
would benefit from an additional
34.2 million pounds
now in an ideal world we would have a uk
government committing to fixing our
broken local government finance system
sadly we do not live in that world and i
will now take you through the steps we
propose to bridge the 20 million pound
budget gap along with the action we will
be taking to meet our future financial
pressures
the 2223 budget gap has not altered
significantly since the publication of
our draft budget in october last year
although announcements have made made at
the spending round followed by
announcements connected to the local
government finance settlement have had
impact on underlying figures supporting
the overall gap
we only saw that gap close from 21.75
million in october to 20.14 million
today
within the council spending round an
assumption was made by the government
that councils would increase council tax
by the corps two percent and a further
one percent for adult social care
precept and that this is one of the
actions we're taking to help out close
our budget gap
this will contribute over three million
pounds towards the revenue budget
traffic has always had low reserves in
comparison with our neighbours and that
remains the case when you strip out the
covered 19 reserves ring fence to meet
the 2021 collection fund shortfall
nevertheless we have undertaken a review
of this year that has enabled us to
redirect resources to support our budget
proposals
we continue to separate our business as
usual pressures from pressures related
to the impact of covert 19 and we
proposed a contribution of just over 7
million pounds from our covert 19
general reserve and 4.33 million pounds
from our budget support reserve
we also set our savings and income
proposals in more detail in annex d of
the papers and forecasts they will
contribute 5.32 million pounds to this
year's budget gap
although we have managed to bridge a
significant budget gap of 20 million
pounds this year we are acutely aware of
the financial challenges ahead as well
as the ongoing uncertainty of a
government government continuing to work
on single year settlements
this is why we're already putting plans
in place to launch a finance and change
programme
this program will carry out service
reviews consider ways of managing
service demand take a digital first
approach and review our asset management
we will develop our finance and change
program by mapping our existing
modernization activity and collaborating
with and learning from other councils
partners and organizations
we will also closely monitor the key
projects and programs required to
deliver the 22-23 budget
the work will be monitored by a new
finance and change board which will come
into effect from next month as we start
to work on our future budgets
the commitment we're showing to the
finance and change programme together
with the proactive approach officers and
members have demonstrated when meeting
the financial challenges we face means
that our section 151 officer has
assessed that our estimates made for the
calculation of the budget are robust
we also welcome his recommendation that
the general reserve increased from 8
million pounds to 9.5 million pounds and
that we continue a 1.5 million pounds
temporary covered contingency budget for
a further 12 months
the budget process takes many months of
work to put together with input from
both officers and members and i would
like to take have taken opportunity to
thank some of the key people who have
contributed to putting this budget set
of budget proposals together
firstly i'd like to thank my colleagues
on the executive and members of the
corporate leadership team
early in the process we had a series of
workshops to consider the budget and how
we align it to our priorities for
trafford
executive colleagues have also engaged
with scrutiny as part of the process
which leads me on to thanking our
scrutiny committee colleagues who have
had a valuable input into the budget
process the quality of questioning
displayed by at the committee meetings i
attended was impressive and showed a
real understanding of the financial
challenges local government continues to
face
i'm very grateful for the report the
committee put together and look forward
to working with scrutiny again in the
future
finally i'd like to take this
opportunity to thank our director of
finance and systems as he comes to the
end of his first year in the role
i said at the end of last at this time
last year that we couldn't wish for a
safer pair of hands to take on this role
and this has proven to be the case
graham is diligent knowledgeable and
keeps calm he gives me a lot of support
in this role and i know that that is
replicated for members across the
council
local government is very fortunate to
have public servants like graham and his
team
i'm proud to present this budget to
council this evening it shows a positive
difference a labour council can make in
our local area
this is a budget that fulfills our
vision for trafford where all our
residents businesses and communities
will prosper whilst offering a big
increase in support to the most
vulnerable people that live in our
borough thank you
thank you councillor ross
is the motion seconded
second chair thank you
i now call upon councillor morgan to
respond to the proposed budget on behalf
of the conservative group councilman
just before council morgan speak to
everybody i can hear
mobile phones or something tinging in
the background
is it that is it is it something there
right
now if we can switch that off
thank you mayor um tonight i'm proud to
be speaking on behalf of my good friend
and colleague councillor myers to
present the conservative group's
position on the 22-23 trafford council
budget
um firstly on behalf of the group i'd
like to thank graham bentley and his
team um for bringing forward a balanced
budget and i'd also like to thank um
thank you to the corporate leadership
team and heads of service i'm sure i've
spent many long hours searching
potential savings and income generation
opportunities um i know from personal
experience the challenges of producing a
budget and i only can imagine having its
subjects suddenly from councils like
myself and the wider world makes it only
more challenging
um firstly in considering the wider
national financial situation as the uk
economy continues to recover from
pandemic
the uk is required to confront the
global inflationary pressures caused by
the world economy coming back to life
much of this inflation is driven by the
rising cost of energy due to increased
demand worldwide along with the global
labor demand shortages and it's feeding
through into pressures on the cost of
loan but our conservative government is
helping trafford residents through the
variety of measures
the government has already taken steps
such as reducing the universal credit
taper rate increasing the national
living wage freezing fuel duty for the
12th year in a row and launching a 500
million pound household support fund to
help the lowest income households with
their bills
following off gems confirmation earlier
in the month that the energy price cap
will rise by 700 pounds from april
the government has announced a
three-part plan to help with um
household fuel bills immediately and
protect people from half of this
increase worth 350 pounds per household
in a total package of support worth 8.6
billion
and this is before the other government
measures to support traffic families
whilst i might not get the exciting news
to focus upon it is the things in the
long term which will matter and will get
our economy moving for everybody
launching the plan for jobs helping
people earn more and gain the skills
the economy needs through a 2 billion
pound kickstart scheme 2.9 billion
restarts scheme and life skills
guarantee the government is helping
people back into work
investing 200 million pounds per year to
help continue the holiday activity and
food programme
keeping the energy price cap in place
this winter helping 15 million um uk
households
save 100 pounds a year at least on their
heating and energy bills
extending the warm home discount to
protect 2.2 million pensions
i'm listening intently to what you've
got to say and i'm very interested it is
but you do seem to be talking a lot
about the government policy
and i do remind you that we are talking
about traffic council's budget
can you can you can you
can we
can i hold you yeah no
so let's talk about the council budget
firstly it's important to say the budget
before us contains many measures which
the conservative group do support such
as additional funding for children adult
social care and sports and leisure
however there are aspects of this budget
we do not agree with and starting with
the proposed increase in council tax
labor's budget will see an average
bandie property paying an a council tax
bill of 1 784 pounds 26 which includes
228 pounds 30 for the mayor's police
charge 102 pounds 95 for the mayor's
general charge
if we take the council's portion that's
up over 200 pounds um since labour came
to power an increase of 20 percent and
then when you look at andy burnham's
portion that's over 100 quid basically a
50 increase from when he became mayor in
2017
at a time when we know our residents are
struggling with living costs and a time
when the council is able to increase its
general reserves
this is not justifiable
parking charges is another area where we
disagree with the labour budget
the proposals are for our town centres
for two-thirds increase from one pound
twenty to two pounds
this is then this is
then topped off with a rise of 14
on residents parking permits from 41
pounds 75 to 47 pounds 50.
and this is a huge increase on residents
during a time when other spending is
going up and is now 23 up from when
labour took charge
and is after disparate despite our pleas
labour refusing to implement a through a
free after three parking initiatives
after christmas
during the worst of the american raid
wave businesses when consumer confidence
was weakened we cannot accept such a
huge rise in costs for local residents
and our small businesses
but we are on the side of the majority
of trafford residents the budget report
itself states 67 of residents to the
parking charges consultation either
disagree or strongly disagree to the
proposed rise and on the
rise in parking permits 57 of residents
disagree
yet labor i've ignored the views of the
majority of traffic residents
and it's not the only charge um to
increase just looking at the
consolidated fees and charges book which
i'm sure all councils have been
reviewing here's just a few the charge
for application for a skip on the road
up 13 to 40 pounds since labour took
charge chargeville um children's
fairground right it's on adopted
highways for a year up 23 to 2400 since
2018.
pest control for grey squirrels up 36
um a basic safety certificate for a new
standard sports grant up 246
alone this year and 300 since 2018
and there's some new charges such as in
34 pounds for swapping to a larger grade
bin hitting a lot hard-working families
at a tough time for them financially
in terms of the savings assumption we
also have some concerns over these
especially the presumed 1.4 million
pounds in children's placements and one
million pounds for waste disposal
in some women
this budget is a tax and charge more
budget
now i'm sure a lot will be said that
this is necessary but
let's look at the government funding for
trafford
through the local government finance
scheme for 2020 to 23 the council's core
spending power is 177.4 million at seven
percent rise since 21 22 since 2018-19
it's up 28.3 million up 19
since 2017 traffic has been part of the
greater manchester 100 business rates
retention pilot benefiting from
significant levels of business rate
funding this then added on to the 20
increase in council tax since labor came
to power and charges through the roof
since entering opposition the
conservative group was always aimed to
have a positive and constructive
approach we have looked at the budgets
in the past and have tried to amend
where possible indeed where enough
amendments have been reasonably accepted
we've not actually we've actually voted
for the controlling labor groups budget
however tonight is not a night we can
accept the labour budget this is a
budget which is taxing and charging more
and more and as anyone who puts out
their bins out and haven't got collected
over the last few years this is a budget
which is delivering less and less we
need a budget that supports residents
and makes it easier for our businesses
to trade and do well this is not a
budget that does this this budget is
rejecting its entirety and starting
impression i urge all colleagues from
across the political spectrum to reject
it tonight thank you
thank you councillor morgan
i now call upon councillor new gross to
respond on behalf of the liberal
democrats group
thank you
i would like to begin by thanking the
officers and staff for the diligent work
and support this year
while preparing the speech i took the
opportunity to look back at what i'd
said in previous years and noted for the
last three years we have faced a
national and global picture of
uncertainty and concern
looking at the wider world today i see
more of the same
perhaps the greatest immediate concern
for our residents is a cost of living
crisis
this is all too evident in the tone of
their voices when they talk about how
they're going to simply afford to live
inflation today reached 5.5 percent and
is predicted by the bank of england to
pass seven percent this year and of
course this is headline rate inflation
the actual lift rate inflation of
necessary unavoidable items such as food
clothing fuel is running far higher
we are now weeks away from an
eye-watering increase in our fuel bills
and almost unbelievable 54
with another insignificant rise on the
cars for october
a huge rise in the basic cost of living
hitting our residents those least able
to afford it hit the hardest
so how is this government responding
well in april we have a 10 national
insurance rise
an avoidable policy change which the
government seems oblivious
and to help with our heating costs a 200
pound loan on our bill this year
repayable over the next four years
can i just tell you about one of my
residents a homeless single mum with a
young toddler after many months on
bidding on host properties she has
finally been successful she will be
moving into her first flat in the coming
weeks
if she misses this energy scheme she
will not only have no support for her
household energy bills but will instead
have the financial insult of paying for
a loan over the next four years that she
never received in the first place it's
not her fault it's a deeply flawed
scheme
the lib dems called for a windfall tax
on uk energy companies labour joined our
position on this and this was before
shell and bp announced 20 billion pounds
in a bumper profit for last year's
trading
there are ways to really mitigate crisis
you know what i'm going i'm setting the
scene sir
there's a new gross can we can we talk
about traffic council budgets i will
just one second i wanted to thank um the
work that our officers have done to help
mitigate covid and get us through it i
include the ccg and residents i'd like
to cherish the fact that
when the going got tough in the traffic
community stepped forward
and dealt with things and it was a
silver lining to an otherwise dark time
so to the budget
firstly i must welcome that we have
achieved against considerable odds
another balanced budget i'd like to
thank officers in their support of this
however even when this budget is passed
we still note a 15 million budget gap
for next year and near 3 million for
24.25
we are not like national government we
can't borrow away out of problems here
we note the rise of cost of running the
borough up to 7.3 percent
something something that will continue
with an aging population and new
population growth with all demand all
the demands they bring
this of course will be compounded by the
inflation that i mentioned earlier
with combined authority precepts our
residents are looking at 3.7 on the
council tax alongside the cost of living
crisis they're facing we should never
forget that and while we pat ourselves
on the back creating a balanced budget
many of our residents will increasingly
struggle over the next year
we see a reduction in public health
spending probably linked to reduced
covig pressures but an area of budget
that should not be cut so easily if we
are to deal with health inequalities
over the coming year in the borough
worryingly we see a reduction in early
years block within the education budget
when we all know early years
intervention done right can provide
children a solid foundation for a
lifetime of success and productivity
we welcome support with energy bills but
let's call it what it is five year loan
and 150 pound council turks rebate this
april
feels more like an action an election
bribe than anything else
especially when you consider those
people just managing but living in a van
d property will hit by all the increases
with no rebate
we welcome the freezing entertainment
charges however small
however maybe a small reduction in the
first six months of the new financial
year would have been more help to our
struggling industry service industry
here in trafford
we welcome indicative capital investment
in the willows primary school of 2.5
million pounds and hope over the future
years other schools in temple village
will also be considered for investment
we also warmly welcome spending on parks
and roads a note timperley has benefited
from sixty thousand pounds of green
space improvements and residents will be
pleased to know that shaspree avenue one
of the gateways of trafford will at long
last be resurfaced
finally we welcome that the parking
charges in timperley have not been
imposed upon us yet and we look forward
to a solution where we can avoid them
being imposed we have repeatedly made
our case that tympiers are unique
amongst other villages in trafford in
that it is surrounded in all directions
by shopping destinations with multiple
supermarkets each with hundreds of free
parking places while timpy village
itself has no such amenity available
it will suffer more than other locations
for a blanket approach to charging and
while i'm on the subject simply our
group welcome regeneration of ernst
altringham stratford sail and hail but
we'll be making the case that tinfley is
next it's timply's turn and we commit to
working with officers to design a
timberly plan in the coming year
onto the investment fund
although the committed 360 million
pounds this fund is still generating a
net gain for the council this year this
year we saw the first losses for
individual investments 1.2 million on a
delayed loan
property developer
and
significant many hundreds of thousand
pounds due to urgent remedial work on
the still closed grafton center the
grafton centre is one of the investments
i singled out in my very first speech
it's one of the investments i know
personally there are a dozen more
investment buildings across the
northwest many with no links to trafford
in wigan warrington preston i hope they
will not also require expensive remedial
work
added to this money we now have set
aside
money for legal action against the
council in relation to one of our
investments
i worry that the new costs like these on
a portfolio we hold may become more
widely needed as part of this the group
intends to move an amendment to the
budget covering the investment fund
i would like to round up with a request
this year as our residence counts every
penny i'd like to ask that more than
ever we ensure there's no waste in
council spending let us not follow the
tory national government's example of
writing off billions to fraud grossly
overpaying for ppe contracts unusable
and out of date pp and of course
absolutely no lucrative secret contacts
to our mates or private donors thank you
thank you councillor newgrosh
thank you for giving us notice of your
amendment
and please can i call on councillor
jerome to respond on behalf of the green
party please
thank you
as a green party we always like to thank
officers and staff throughout the
council for the tireless work they do in
putting this budget together
the challenges of covert 19 have lasted
longer than anyone would have expected
and graham in his first year in his lead
role in finance has probably dealt with
one of the most challenging set of
figures ever
officers from all over the council are
continually working with ever tighter
budgets having to be ever more
resourceful and creative in cutting
costs and helping to produce a legal and
balanced budget it's a remarkable job so
thank you
at january executive scrutiny committee
reported back on this year's draft
budget one concern was how the public
would perceive the use of reserves and
how we would communicate this i put this
point to the executive member for
finance counselor ross who simply said
this is the job of councillors and i do
believe he's right it's part of our job
to come to convey the complex reports
figures seems in an honest and
understandable way in fact as greens we
we made it a principle to do politics in
a mature way and work with others where
we have common goals however over the
year we have seen issues kicked around
this chamber like a political football
tory's verbally ripping up cones from
the a56 lib dems and tories fighting to
offer the most freest parking in temple
village and labour watering down the
climate action even on our own website
let alone the clean air debacle which is
leaving people in a dangerous levels of
air pollution for another four years
so how would i begin to explain this
budget to a resident well
it comes after a period of over 10 years
of central government cutting funds to
local authorities year on year it comes
off the back of a world pandemic where
councils are left to pick up the
majority of the costs
over the last year this government is
drunkenly sailing this nation into a
cost of living crisis like like many of
us will never have seen before and to
keep this budget afloat we're having to
raid reserves lifting our council tax to
its near legal limit of 2.99
further hurting people's pockets and
charting a very uncertain course ahead
but what's the good news a resident may
ask
well
their public realm improvements are 1.54
million and the second phase of the
future street fund of 17.6 million will
see the continued regeneration of our
strategic town centres earnston
stratford sale and altringham this money
will continue to revitalize these
centres with evidence-based improvements
that will see them remain an attractive
offer that can weather the future
economic ups and downs
we will see our legislators refreshed
and money for our sports provision with
8.2 million worth of funding
there will there will also be extra
money for making sure this is done
sustainably with the addition of heat
pumps and other sustainable measures in
the build at ultranam leisure center
as ultron ultringham councillors we are
pleased to see alfred oldfield road and
moss lane included in our road
maintenance budget there will be 311k
for resurfacing these badly worn roads
we're also pleased to see ultron of town
hall now an asset of community value
potentially potentially least
with uses meeting the core community
values this building needs to be used
and maintained
could the council be doing better
well
we have the amy seven-year review which
is a crucial chance to revisit our
capital program to modernize create
extra revenue and do things better with
our private contract amy officers have
told us
we must win more grants and we must make
better use of the grants that we do have
it's good to see that we've got 3.61
million for walking and cycling in money
largely made up of the marriage
challenge fund and emergency travel
grants though this money was 4.3 in
2020's budget and has probably sat there
largely untouched
it's appreciated that cycling schemes
have been delayed
we do appreciate that cycling schemes
have been delayed due to land ownership
design process and consultation however
if you look at the north ultraman
bridgewater scheme it's due in june 2024
and it will be 10 years since its
inception
however we need to break our car
dependency and create infrastructure to
meet our carbon reduction targets tackle
air pollution and create active
healthier lives
the executive must take some
responsibility on the speed of delivery
and making this money work
the executive member for the environment
has failed to engage with groups like
the traxford cycle forum in a meaningful
way so schemes have been messily
deployed the leader has been sidelined
by the noise created by small minority
groups and not made the solid public
health arguments that exist within his
own council and we still have no cycling
strategy in this council
this council will spend 40k on 20 mile
an hour zones
doing this in a pieced mill an isolated
way is not cost effective both labour
and tories support by rewi 20's plenty
in opposition but somehow find arguments
against an executive
it is produ it is proven to reduce speed
of curves
lower pollution and rebalances our road
to roads to walking and cycling
an investment that will save money in
the long run
i was pleased to see the scrutiny review
this year and it shows that having
robust procedures for keeping the
executive check and delivering value for
residents is a good thing however i
would argue that still getting the best
outcomes and not
pointing the right issues is still a
problem
scrutiny can be a vehicle for making
good decisions and creating better value
for our residents green councillors have
experienced problems with the council
when accessing contracts and guarantees
on par play equipment meaning they're
often not replacing like for like and
ultimately what wasting money on items
that could be replaced for free
the green party will be will keep
attending scrutiny committee as
non-voting members and demand that
better uptake of issues and more
meaningful outcomes are derived
the council's spending power should be a
force for our values and commitments the
star procurement allows us to have
to save and add value by maximizing our
purchase power by joining with other
councils
carb induction is a commitment but it
needs to be effectively audited so we
can see and measure progress and use our
influence as a major per purchaser
though it makes good savings we're not
seeing the carbon reduction in in our
spending power
what does the future hold for residents
well the growing costs due to inflation
the demand from services such as adult
and social care will not go away
finance officers have told us that using
reserves like we are is just sticking
plaster and not financially prudent the
financial change programme will now look
at our non-statutory functions and we've
been told that nothing is off the table
and there is nothing sacred and
efficiencies and cuts will have to be
made this is a truly worrying picture
for the services that residents rely on
our climate emergency now four years old
needs brave leadership leadership strong
delivery and cr and creativity and
making the change we need though
positive steps have been made we're not
going fast enough
we're still investing eight million
pounds of developer contributions in the
carrington link road increasing motor
vehicle capacity lightly taken up by
heavily polluting hgvs
the decisions
that were made without the recommended
ecological assessments
we are also still dependent
on the airport
which is now costing us deer financially
and in carbon we need to be moving away
from such carbon heavy investments
we recognize that with each year
that balance in budgets is getting
painfully difficult we will be
supporting this budget but we've made
our reservations clear and we will be
watching closely as the jury is out for
progress over the next year
thank you jeff thank you councillor
jerome
i now propose to deal with the
amendments councillor newgross gave
notice of an amendment
and they're now asked that this be moved
please without further comment comes a
new crush
so i hope you all have sight of the
amendment it is that this council agrees
to reduce the upper limit of borrowing
in assassin investment strategy from 500
million to 400 million over the next
three financial years the council
recognises that phase reduction in
borrowing is in line with longer-term
aims of the asset investment strategy
so the purpose of this amendment is to
commit the council to phasing down the
upper limit of trafford's borrowing over
the next three years
the amendment is in line with the
medium-term objectives of the catholic
council's asset investment strategy as
we are already achieving the target
income within a 360 million of current
financial con
commitment
if our goal is to build a resilient
financial change program this council
must be less resilient on its reserves
and must also minimize exposure to debt
risk
this amendment commits traffic to a
gradual reduction in the upper limit of
the investment strategy it does not need
to impact any of the spending outlined
in this year's budget
revenue budget the purpose of the
three-year time frame is to allow the
council on the investment board
particularly the flexibility as it seeks
to become less dependent on borrowing to
raise funds
the liberal democrats have voiced
concern about the risk posed by the
asset investment strategy on numerous
occasions and now we remain deeply
concerned about the exposure that comes
with such high borrowing limits
it also gives flexibility and
importantly headroom for the council to
deliver its com or already stated
commitments to regeneration
but the wider point here is that
trafford should not have to incur debt
on speculative investments in order to
fund the work we do it
to move our communities forward the only
reason we have to do that is because a
conservative government in westminster
which is focused on stripping as much
power and resources possible from local
government
i hope that councils can support this
prudent direction to the investment
committee thank you
thank you councillor new grosh
is the amendment seconded
councillor brophy
your wish to speak
okay
um does anyone wish to speak to the
amendment
hang on
leader
the initial
request is a point of order for
a ruling from the section one five
officer was to the province or otherwise
of the amendment because whilst
councillor new brush
suggested it was prudent looking at it
against our budget assumptions for this
year i'm not clear if that is the case
given that any amendment to the [ __ ]
just one second grant can you just
introduce yourself to everybody yeah i'm
graeme bentley i'm director of finance
and systems i'm thinking of the public
watching section
thank you
given that any amendment to the budget
could become part of the 2223 budget
calculations i have to consider the
impact the proposed amendment could have
on the robustness of the estimates and
on the adequacy of reserves
i've carried out an assessment of the
proposed amendment and in doing so i
have drawn on the views of directors and
senior officers of the council
responsible for the relevant service and
budget areas
the objective of the asset investment
fund is to support the council's
strategic priorities
whilst creating a suitable income stream
to support local services
therefore in considering the amendment
i've had to assess it against the plans
for using the fund for future
regeneration schemes in the borough
and also the levels of income generated
to support the cost of council services
estimates of which are assumed in the
medium financial plan in 2223 and later
years
any reduction to the fund in 2223
could impact on the level of assumed
income in the mtfp
this would require the further use of
one-off reserves to ensure
balanced budget position in that year i
feel that any further use of reserves to
support the 2223 budget position would
not be prudent
my opinion is that whilst a phase
reduction to the fund may align to plans
in the mtfp for 23-24 onwards the scale
of the reduction of 100 million has
potential to have a negative impact on
the budget assumptions and is therefore
something i believe would need further
consideration once market conditions
become more stable following the corvid
pandemic
reducing the fund
this much has potential to affect the
amounts available to sport regeneration
schemes in the borough an impact on the
income streams currently assumed in the
mtfp from 2034
which this could give rise to a need to
deliver alternative budget savings which
would not be prudent given the size of
the remaining budget gap in those years
i feel it would be more appropriate to
scale
to review the scale and phasing of any
reduction to the fund as part of the
setting of the budget for 23.24
thank you
are you done
thanks chair um
as members will know
we are not in the habit of accepting
amendments which the section 151 officer
deems imprudent
clearly there is 7.6 million pounds
worth of income projected to come into
our coffers
this financial year 2022 23 that we are
dealing with tonight on that basis and
in the absence of any alternative to
plug that gap this is not something we
could support i appreciate that council
negros is intimating that this could be
phased but of course if you are looking
to phase over three years one would
assume that that would be
something that would include a reduction
in year one if not
then there is absolutely no reason why
as the section 151 officer suggests we
couldn't review this as part of next
year's budget setting so on that basis
chair we will be opposing the amendment
thank you thank you
do any members wish to speak to the
amendment
i've just got two speakers councillor
evans and councillor jerome is that is
anybody else indicated the council of
books thank you
council book would you like to go first
please council of mercer
i've got council of mercer councillor
book councillor evans councillor jerome
any other members wishing to speak to
the amendment
no okay council of both would you like
to be clear
yeah we're speaking to the amendment
yeah
council mercer doesn't want to speak
you don't want to speak to your member
okay council the book would you like to
go first please you don't want to speak
to the amendment
council reverend would you like to speak
to the amendment
thank you councillor evans
thank you chair um i'm conscious of what
section 151 officer has said but i think
actually this would be uh achievable
achievable and we have in the past uh
supported amongst multitude of
investments made by the investment
management board
um however i'm conscious
and i set on the board and but i've got
increased doubt about some of the new
investments that the council has been
mating making and the council's appetite
for risk seems to have increased
somewhat this amendment would be
at least a way of controlling
the potential risk as we move forward so
um
council new russia conservative group
will
support your amendment and i think uh
with some prudent
uh management this could be uh
guided through by the section 151
officer thank you thank you council
evans councillor jurong
thanks chair this
amendment has come quite late and it's
come in a very brief form so it
we've not really had time to look at the
framework that councillor newgrosh is
suggesting so in responding to this it's
always crucial to understand the
thoughts of our financial director first
he clearly doesn't think this is prudent
um it could lead to extra use of
river reserves and it's too dangerous
within our financial constraints over
the medium-term projections
we should also remember the government
has made good changes to the way
councils invest their money
they should go they should be local and
they should have value for residents of
this borough trafford in adopting this
has also set its own principles for
investment which includes regeneration
and sustainability and a commitment to
carbon reduction
the investment management board allows
us to hold
hold to account on this of course the
green party is not always happy with the
investments but we do have a voice to
hold to account and persuade it is
worrying indeed to see
that you know some members
don't always turn up but even more
worrying is that the lib dems bring this
amendment and refuse to take their place
as they refuse to accept the
understandable commercial sensitivity
there's been some good examples of these
investments stretford mall rackhams and
the sale magistrates it means these
assets are brought within public
ownership with a set of principles and
policies behind their future development
that seems to me to be a good thing so
it's ironic that the tories and the lib
dems were the authors of the austerity
program in 2010 and the reason that many
of councils were starting
start make stuff started making such bad
investments to create income generation
to prop up budgets however the situation
i think is starting to change and we
will not be supporting
um this last minute um and very brief
amendment which doesn't really explain
the full framework that's being
suggested thanks to
thank you councillor jerome does
councillor wash
russ wish to reply to the amendment
please
thank you mayor i i will do very briefly
um i do get concerned about some of the
language used about the asset investment
strategy by people from parties that
continue to boycott the management board
the liberal democrats have an open
invitation to join us on that
cross-party board and take part in the
dialogue they refuse and instead bring
these motions to council which as the
section 151 officer has said could put
our borough's finances for the next year
at risk if we were to accept it
i think um council jerome has made a
series of good points about the strategy
um indeed we have revised the strategy
in recent years we focus on place-based
and economic regeneration it is doing a
number of good things and it continues
to bring in a very
helpful
um
multi-million pound um
revenue to our revenue budget every
single year
this kind of behavior may read well and
look good for leaflets but actually
you're playing with the borough's
finances in a way that you don't quite
understand because you don't turn up to
the meetings so i would really like to
see you in the new municipal year join
us
and have some positive dialogue with us
as we proceed with the rest of the
investment strategy thank you please do
vote against this amendment
thank you councillor ross i shall now
put the amendment to the vote
those in favor of the amendment please
raise your hands
okay hands down
and those against please
have we got those ian yeah hands down
please are there any abstentions
no abstentions that amendment is lost
everybody that moment is lost
um
so we've
we're moving on to the main motion now
um any members wishing to speak to the
main motion
please do keep your hands up and uh
be patient with me
hands down everybody and i'll just read
out who i've got and if your name isn't
called please please tell me
um
councillor freeman councillor patel
counselor i said
counselor
i can't read that one
councillor taylor councillor hawkey
councillor welton
councillor coggins
councillor hartley councillor board
councillor mersa council of wetton
council of western the leader
somebody wasn't counted the current
answer
i'm sorry somebody else
two
times
so everybody want to speak oh council
boys of course
okay so everybody's heard their name
right now
okay we'll start with councillor hartley
comes largely
thank you matt um
we heard from kendall morgan a while ago
and it appears that he wants to enjoy
one of the luxuries of opposition that
is um having a cake and eating it
because
in one breath he complained about the
three percent increase in cancer tax and
of course we'd rather not see cancer
attacks go up but then just a few
moments later he made much of the
increasing core spending power that the
government announced for local
government
despite a lot of that being based on
the assumption that council tax would go
up by the maximum allowed so that
assumption of the increase in council
tax
was baked into the government's uh one
year financial settlement
and much of the remainder of that
increase in spending power was one-off
grants as well
and of course that comes on the back of
10 years of cuts to council funding
the prime minister urged councils to do
whatever it takes during the pandemic
and to be reimbursed
but we're still out of pocket for that
we've got one year financial settlements
meaning we can't plan for the long-term
future
delayed fair funding review delayed
business rates review
but we've still managed to set a
balanced budget that protects frontline
services
and we should be thankful really that
councilman morgan and his colleagues
aren't charged with the responsibility
of leading the council and setting the
budget because of course it wasn't too
long ago under their watch that we saw
surestart children's centers close we
saw frontline services cut
we saw them doing the bidding of their
masters hollowing out the council
so it became uh on a course to become a
commissioner of services that the
council was statutorily obliged to
provide
but what a difference a labor council
makes because we're investing in our
residents to alleviate poverty locally
we're investing in measures to achieve
carbon neutrality by 2038 we're
investing in affordable housing
and most importantly my view we're inves
investing in the future of our borough
we're investing in our children and
we're investing 20 million pounds
in our schools
expanding school places to meet demand
investing investing in scn provision 1.7
million on that investing in the first
primary the willows primary temple more
infants moreland uh moorland's junior
and david hume primary and many other
schools
so we can see that this is the
difference that a labour council makes
and
i'm thankful to to council staff for
working hard during these extremely
trying circumstances and i'm grateful to
councillor ross and the executive for
coming up with such a positive budget
for the future so i'll be supporting the
budget motion thank you thank you
council hartley we've got 15 speakers
and we've got 30 minutes
to do it until i'm afraid everyone's
gonna have to reduce their speeches to
two minutes please um councilor merza
please
as we know the new vision for our
borough is trafford where all our
residents communities and businesses
prosper and in achieving that vision we
have key outcomes set out in the budget
at paragraph 2.1.7
on page 24. this reads that the key
outcomes are all our residents will have
access to quality learning training and
jobs all our communities will be happy
healthy and safe all our businesses and
town centres will be supported to
recover and flourish for the benefit of
everyone but i have great concerns with
the manner in which these outcomes are
drafted
the budget fails to indicate what
success would look like
the budget fails to set out any
meaningful targets or specific goals in
these areas
and the budget fails to set out any
measurable figures or percentages
whilst the key outcomes themselves are
meritorious and ones which each and
every one of us here today would like
our council to aspire to
our residents and businesses however
deserve measurable targets
rather than a blanket wish list which
only goes to make a good headline
at present
the manner in which these outcomes are
set out in the budget is wholly
inadequate
it disallows proper scrutiny and
accountability on these outcomes to take
place
or indeed for us to recognize that
specific targets set are indeed achieved
this is disappointing and yet again
another opportunity missed
thank you councillor merza um
councillor freeman please
thank you chair i'm just in response to
councillor mercer he might do well to
read our corporate plan i think he's
referring to that um i recall back in
2012 when first elected to the council
being informed by then conservative
councillor that all the problems faced
by the council were the direct results
of a labour government failing to fix
the roof uh in the good times resulting
in austerity being the only way to put
this right wheelchair austerity didn't
fix the roof because the roof leaked and
as a result of conservative policies our
residents our staff and this council are
poorer now than we were back in 2012.
and i know those opposite will always
say they had no choice but the truth of
what they did to this council is plain
for all to see and one reason why they
should never ever ever be allowed to
regain control of this council and i
think their current 16 seats is a fair
reflection of how our residents view
them their proud boast of being the
party of fiscal responsibilities where
it belongs in tatters in the bin
now as part of our budget you will see
investment in systems and assets to
improve the way
work and much the way we work how much
of this will be invested in our digital
strategy in gaining control of the
council in 18 we were left by those
opposite with no i.t strategy no digital
strategy one of the many things that we
are in the process of rectifying our
digital strategy is based on five themes
digital borough digital services digital
workforce digital organization and
digital support combined together these
themes will see the way we work as a
council and access
the way we work as a council and the
access to services for our residents
improve in addition we are committed to
ensuring all of our residents can come
become digitally connected uh our
digital community grant scheme being an
example of how we can help community
groups make the difference and i'm
pleased to announce tonight that workers
now commenced on a new crm system for
this council and there'll be
opportunities for everyone in this room
to have an input into in into that
system
in terms of our workforce we've been
migrating to microsoft 365 from windows
10 the process will be commenced this
will have all sorts of meetings
for information sharing enhanced remote
working and hybrid meetings
we are an ambitious council under labour
and we're determined to provide the best
services for our residents whilst
ensuring value for money and our budget
does exactly that and i commend it to
all in this room thank you thank you
councillor
councillor wilson please
thank you
much of the controversy about around
this budget seems to be around the rise
in the cost of parking and we totally
understand the concern of members with
any rise in the cost of living
particularly during these times of high
inflation and skyrocketing energy prices
however i think we need an alternative
perspective on parking permits in
particular a permit allows a user to
leave their vehicle in the street 24 7
365 days a year for the cost of 47
pounds 50 a year if a parking space is
usually around 11 meters square that's
only a rise of 31 pence to 36 p
per month for each meter square of
public space i would ask members to
consider this is there any other sphere
of human life
where property is priced so cheaply by
contrast rent for a two-bedroom house in
sale is 11 pounds a month
per square meter or a shop in altringham
is 5 pounds 49 a month per square meter
looked on from this perspective the
price of a parking permit is not so
expensive it's actually massively
subsidized particularly when one
considers the opportunity cost in
alternative positive uses of this
valuable public space how many pavements
could be widened trees could be planted
roads could be narrowed and cycle lanes
built in the space occupied by park
parked cars so let's be clear keeping on
street parking so cheap is a political
choice not one guided by economics
what i really don't understand is why we
keep parking permits at a flat rate for
everyone after all vehicles don't come
in a single size why is a small car that
takes up relatively little little room
charged the same as a huge suv why is a
vehicle with a clean modern engine
charged the same as a vehicle with an
older more polluting engine
many other councils around the country
now have variable charges for parking
permits based on a vehicle's dimensions
or engine size trafford and sticking
with a flat rate for old vehicles is
persisting with a system that is both
inequitable and fails to incentivize
residents to own the smaller cleaner
vehicles that have fewer negative
external externalities for our
communities thank you
thank you councillor welton can i take
one of the characters please
after you
you have two minutes councilor carter
thank you chad
councillor morgan listed many proposed
charges and taxes that the tories do not
support and i think we can infer
that they would not impose these charges
or the council tax increase
may i restate the 2.99 council tax
increase
uh proposed is baked into the
government's own plans council morgan
appears to disagree with his chancellor
how convenient
he also doesn't support charges
that changes to parking charges or to
assorted fees and charges i'm not going
to explore this to the depth of the
color of squirrels
so these tory ideas cost money
got a tory council who's therefore
while infers proposing net spending
commitments without proposing any
alternative budget plan
don't know about you but i think that's
just a bit embarrassing
this is council not a letter to santa
and where trafford borough council not a
tory government spending for its own
political benefit and wantonly writing
off billions in fraud
hard choices and diligent work deserve
better than this tory fantasy funding
wish list
i sit on the scrutiny committee in the
accounting audit committee in a regular
which regularly review trafford
council's expenditure and financial
plans i regularly ask opposition members
on these committees to engage offering
their suggestions for how to address the
budget in austere times
i regularly hear nothing in reply
saving your unfunded uncosted
suggestions for six weeks before the
financial year sounds a bit
silly to me
i hope saying so doesn't put me on
santa's naughty list thank you thank you
councillor canada councillor butts
please
hello
just wanted to pick up on two points uh
and that the first one is while the
budget details 500 000
uh pounds of additional investment in
traffic leisure cic
plus 215k on an annualized basis over
five years in its risk reserve and a
capital investment of 8.2 million in the
leisure strategy and sports facilities
provision the conservative group
believes however that the budget has
missed an opportunity to invest in new
leisure centres for altering themselves
threatened
december 2021 trafford council executive
meeting the council agreed to move to
new strategy the stages in its plans to
refurbish altering them sale and
stretford leisure centers
the decision was a reversal of a 2018
decision to build new legend centers in
alternate stratford at the cost of
around 46 million the council had also
previously agreed to bring forward a
business case for capital funding
relating to the development of sale as
your center
few traffic legend members or visitors
to the centers would argue against new
investment but we're likely anticipating
something more than just a refurbishment
of what our tired and dated leisure
centers the people of trafford were
expecting new state-of-the-art carbon
neutral energy efficient facilities
but now are being told to settle for
second best the conservative group on
trafford council is calling on the
labour administration to visit the
refurbishment proposals and commence a
wider review of the leisure offering
trafford reducing health inequalities
and the first priority of the council's
newly refurbished corporate plan and the
journey that the council is embarked on
regarding trafford's leisure's offer
does not provide us with confidence that
there will be more accessible uh
physical activities and sports sessions
available in the community on the other
point i wanted to make was the concern
about the staggering rise on the
reviewing an annual safety certificate
for some of our sports clubs grounds
uh i mean to take example octagon
football club which is going to see us
almost 600 percent rise uh in its
certificate
it's only a seven and a half thousand
capacity
uh also we've got to lance cricket club
which is seeing a 430 percent increase
for the certificate safety certificate
and so the sale rugby club which is seen
1341 staggering rise uh for this case so
it's disproportionate compared to our
flagship stadium which is the united one
which you see in the 4.2 percent thank
you councillor thank you thank you
councillor patel please
thank you chair
i too would like to thank officers for
all their hard work and support in
putting together this budget it's been
another challenging year in which local
government has again been tested to the
extreme
whilst we've had to make some very
difficult decisions there is much to be
welcomed in this budget
i am proud that this budget supports our
transformative plans for our leisure
services and more broadly our ambitions
to increase physical activity in the
borough through investment in our
sporting facilities green spaces and
cycling and walking infrastructure we
are working towards a
once-in-a-generation investment
programme into our leisure centres
members here are all very much welcome
to visit move ernst a refurbished
leisure centre that is performing
extremely well which is evolving as a
genuine example of what could be
achieved at our other centres
public consultation results around
ultranumb are currently being considered
and business cases for sale and
stratford are well underway
this year we'll see a reach real
progress something that i know our
residents will be very glad to see
to councillor buck's point the 46
million um figure he talked about for
new builds on altringham and stretford i
don't believe those plans ever included
for sale are well out of date and
inflation terms around new builds
and around the associated land
acquisitions that we needed to um
acquire well out of date they had 14
years in power to make a real difference
they neglected our leisure centres we're
the ones that are making genuine
attempts to refurbish them for the good
of our residents
thank you councillor patel
councillor taylor please
thank you matt
i am proud to endorse this budget and
would like to place on on record my
thanks to graeme bentley and the
councillors for the council's finance
team and also to councillor ross for
their assiduous work in preparing this
budget in the most challenging and
uncertain circumstances for over a
decade the tory-led government has
systematically and ruthlessly starved
local authorities of their central
funding settlement funding has
diminished by almost 30 percent in the
last six to seven years it is against
this background including the fact that
trafford receives the lowest capital
funding per capita in greater manchester
that tough spending decisions have been
made
this budget is robust and balanced and
demonstrates the values of equality
social justice and compassion true labor
values in protecting the most vulnerable
in our communities with investment in
children and adult social care
ensuring that our residents safety
well-being and dignity come first
it also upholds this labour
administration's commitment to a green
agenda seizing opportunities to build a
low carbon and inclusive digital economy
including decarbonisation works on civic
buildings expansion of ev charging
points and increased use of digital
services
investment in our business
infrastructure and leisure and arts
facilities are also given priority to
ensure trafford is a great place to live
work and play
to produce a balanced ambitious and
forward-thinking budget in such
straightened times underpinned by values
of fairness and an undertaking to tackle
the climate crisis
one from which all traffic trafford
residents will benefit is to be
commended and i am very pleased to give
it my support and i urge all members to
do the same thank you matt thank you
council taylor councillor ted
you can stay there counselor i said or
you can go over to the table
thank you uh chair uh you can start i'd
just like to address a council jerome
first about the walk in the cycling
structure if
he'd actually bothered to actually
approach me in the first place i could
have told him it's almost complete i've
advised certainly one of his colleagues
and other colleagues from the council
who've actually asked me we've been
working on it obviously over the last
couple of years or so since we asked for
it however covert has delayed the work i
used a preset said you simply asked me i
could have told you that so moving on to
the
budget itself i'd just like to comment
really on the capital programme and some
of the major highways works for key
infrastructure proposals which are
around 12 and a half million pounds
this includes around 2 million pounds on
the service and reconstruction and
around three and a half million pounds
teleport on resurfacing type treatments
and dressing work at this this
particular aspect we have expanded over
the next couple of years significantly
meaning that hundreds of residential
streets around traffic can expect to see
such work on the road over the coming
couple of years something which i'm
really pleased to be able to say and
also i'm sure they're welcomed by people
across the border along with that we
have some 335k on intercreated
transports which it does include some
monies for 20 zones which is been a
clear aspiration and hopefully over the
next couple of years can be expanded i
continue to raise this at gm level for
more support and lobbying and in
addition we have some 500k on street
lighting in addition to this course we
have the mayor's challenge fund and
highways england typescript and over the
next few years even when they all get
completed we're looking around an
investment of some 40 million pounds
which obviously include the urban active
neighborhood which will be one of the
large which will be the largest of this
type of scheme across all the greater
manchester to help make a highway safer
for all users and i'm sure you would
agree that would be a record to be proud
of now there was some around greater
manchester about some
people in this council and indeed uh
residents outside of the country sort of
just we've not been ambitious enough now
if we take something like that apart
from 40 million pounds into such schemes
i hope you would agree that isn't
really ambitious for us and i think
we've done really well to get a lot of
those so i'll leave it at that
if it could share thank you thank you
councillor
carter please
actually i'll go over there you can't
hear can you when people are speaking
that way
um
just building on what councillor hartley
said thank you to councillor ross and to
the whole finance team i'd like to draw
members attention to the
19.77 million spend on the investment in
school infrastructure
as well as expanding some of our
mainstream schools this is part of our
invest to save strategy
we're expanding the special schools in
order to keep more children in borough
so this money includes additional
classes at longford park
that picked
an additional specialist class at the
firs
we're reconfiguring the early years at
delamere
and and i'm looking at mrs young because
she's really campaigned for this an
additional specialist class at
wellington high school
to particularly serve the needs of
children with autism and communication
needs that will open this september
i'm sure members will agree that this is
an excellent use of funding enabling
more children to stay closer to home and
benefit from our excellent education
system in trafford thank you thank you
councillor coggins please
thank you mayor i wanted to comment
briefly on the uh climate implications
of this budget and we do welcome the
progress we've made i see an 11
reduction on council estate and which is
good progress is not what we need but it
is good progress and it's also progress
to have it reported here in the budget
as well and we need to remember what
that 11
doesn't include it doesn't include our
dependence on the airport and support
for increasing the size of the airport
and the implications of building a new
road across carrington moss and of
course it doesn't include the impacts of
the one billion pound our pension fund
is using to prop up the biggest dirtiest
most polluting industries in the world
so it is it is good progress but we have
to set it in context and similarly other
comments um
the carbon literacy program described as
ambitious in this report i'm told
actually 20 people were trained over the
course of the last year in it and so
again we just need a little bit more
frankness in in our conversation about
this and i heard councillor hartley
describe our um plans to achieve carbon
neutrality by 2038 of course we don't
have a worked out plan to do that we
have an aspiration to do that which is
very very different and of course yes it
requires huge change from government but
it requires more from our local council
too um similarly i see the citizens
panel is described in the report is
happening in the spring i believe it is
now delayed until late autumn so that
will be four years after our climate
emergency declaration so welcome the
progress but we need to remember the
things that we aren't including and the
yawning gaps we need to change
um very briefly can i just also cancer
freeman um mentioned that the
conservative group is a fair
representation of 16th just to remind
you all none of us have a fair
representation if we had a fair a fair
system we would have at least seven
green councillors here based on last
time's voting okay thank you thank you
councillor coggins councillor boys
please
uh thank you mayor
may i first echo the comments of other
members in thanking our director of
finance graham bentley and the whole of
the finance team which does such
sterling work not only on the budget but
throughout the year i will soon finish a
continuous stretch sounds like a
sentence of 10 years as a member of the
accounts and audit committee which
strange as it may seem i've enjoyed
immensely so i really do know how good
they are
turning to this year's budget all
members will know how passionate i have
always been about our parks and green
spaces especially the little known more
nook for which i am one of the four
founding members of its friends group
and indeed i continue to remain very
actively involved
i was particularly pleased therefore to
see that at last year's june executive
within the park's capital spend a
renewal of equipment at moornook and a
refresh of the young children's play
area at walton park were to be included
in the 2021 2022 parks capital programme
sadly neither will even be started this
current year
however i am pleased to know that in
this year's budget papers perhaps
following some continued pressure from
me they are again listed in the
2022-23 program at a stated total cost
of some 44 000 pounds out of a total
spend of only 126 000 on refurbish
i am however concerned that these appear
to be shown as new projects rather than
a re-profile of projects carried over
from the current year
since residents have been constantly
asking me for progress updates i
sincerely hope these projects will not
reappear in the 23-24 program having
once again not been completed
finally
20 mile an hour limits and zones
i believe that since june when this came
to an exact meeting there had been a
huge number of requests for
consideration of 20 mile an hour zones
do we really believe that 40 000 pounds
will even tackle the tip of the iceberg
i think there will be thousands of very
disappointed residents with such a small
son thank you thank you council boys
council hands please
thank you mayor
and i'm proud that at a time of such
significant pressure we're proposing a
budget that doesn't cut our frontline
services
since labour became the administration
the council has invested in innovative
measures which deliver better outcomes
and improve lives whilst also delivering
savings
and i want to talk a little bit about
what that means for vulnerable children
and families
this year we're proposing to invest 1.5
million pounds into children's social
care
that will support early help working
with schools to ensure families get the
help they need when they need it and
preventing difficulties from escalating
we're we're engaging with collaborative
gm projects to support our young people
leaving care to build their lives and
their future
we've reduced caseload sizes for social
workers by creating additional posts
with a further 21 frontline social
worker posts being added this year
this will include extra social workers
to build on the recruitment and support
for foster carers and we're proposing to
save money through innovation around our
targeted high cost placements which we
actually achieved this year 1.5 million
pounds of savings through this type of
innovation closing a gap of over 20
million pounds after 12 years of
austerity in two years of a pandemic is
incredibly challenging
but there isn't a choice when it comes
to finding the 20 million pounds there
are only choices in how we do this and
we've chosen to do it in a way that
supports and protects people
simply saying you won't put up car
parking charges it isn't sensible or
prudent and we won't do that at the
expense of investing in our children and
families and our frontline services
thank you mayor thank you councillor
heinz councillor wetton please
uh to begin with can i say uh you see
this budget
the distinct
influence of kobit
and has the tail end of big pandemic
measures washing through
as such various elements are influenced
but we don't do now move forward
possibly to somewhat bumpier
times
so just to make a point on the general
reserve i appreciate that the amount has
been increased
shall we say prudently
i would just ask though is that increase
enough
i say this because the shock and awe of
power and fuel increases
not yet
ever by any means
another wave of increases dates
europe into war
fuel and power feed into the price that
to enter price increases and more
inflation
provisioning the accounts for pay and
inflation at 2.39 million
doesn't sound enough
the report concedes
uncertainty relating to paying
conditions in the social care market
will continue for the foreseeable future
and inflation whilst not out of control
is a reminder to those of us of my age
of the old days
demand-led budgets two million pounds
provision is that enough
uh now i don't want to induce the
predictable response well what shall we
cut in order to do that
if we keep it in the adult world and
perhaps re-examine something like the
smoothing and business risk reserves
a very old friend of the officers
with an estimated balance now of 14
million dropping by only 1.3 million
over the next two years
that surely gives scope for an
adjustment from one reserve to another
to bolster
various of the
general reserve headers that will likely
come under pressure in the coming year
i fully realize that there are a number
of reserves in there
i need you to draw to a conclusion i'll
conclude that thank you thank you very
much councillor heart of our last
speaker this evening
in 2018 before i was elected i was
really proud that trafford council
understood the seriousness of the
situation that we are in declared a
climate emergency i'd like to quote some
great mancunians the pancakes who live
just outside my ward and say it's deeds
not words that matter and the devil is
as always in the detail and that's i'm
happy to be here to talk about what this
labour council is doing to address the
climate emergency in this budget
since
that declaration was made we have been
through a horrendous two years with our
residents our businesses and our
services have all been under intense
pressure caused by the global pandemic
however as a council we have been under
an additional continued fiscal pressure
due to chronic underfunding by central
government and we have been for some 12
years
243 million pounds of pressures and
budget gaps since 2010
however in today's labour budget
proposal we have stayed true to our
commitments and are focused on a green
recovery a recovery which will get us to
zero carbon and whilst doing so also
provides better health and well-being
for our residents we know there's an
intersection where public health
improves as people breathe cleaner air
where active travel is not only
recommended but facilitated whether that
be by cycle lanes and low traffic
neighborhoods or by introducing school
streets and discouraging short car
journeys we will reduce our carbon
footprint and improve outcomes for our
residents it's incumbent on us all to
reduce our emissions significantly and
we at trafford council are leading by
example on this by reducing our own co2
emissions by 11
between april 2020 and april 2021 with a
carbon neutral action plan which sets
out 100 actions we can take to
decarbonize our own operations over the
next 10 years there are huge
opportunities for green growth and for
well-paid highly skilled green jobs to
come to trafford but we all have our
part to play in getting to carbon
neutrality and the budget we are voting
on this evening shows us to be
increasing the amount of household waste
which we send for recycling we are
encouraging active travel and increasing
number of electrical vehicle charging
points in the borough i was delighted to
see recent planning applications for
solar panels on a local school and as a
council we're investing in our staff
offering training and carbon literacy
and showing genuine leadership and
giving this climate emergency the focus
it deserves trafford as a council are
definitely a truffle a council of deeds
not words and i would ask you to support
this ambition in this budget here this
evening
thank you very much as agreed at the
beginning of the meeting the opposition
group leaders will now have five minutes
to wind up
councillor jerome please you have five
minutes
thanks jeff
it's clear that we are entering
difficult times for our residents who
will find it increasingly difficult to
make ends meet over the coming years
the budget does deliver essential health
for those that find themselves in
difficult circumstances it's good to see
the continuing support in this budget
the council's taxes support scheme for
those on low income
which costs the council in the region of
13 million a year trafford assist scheme
provides a range of support to
vulnerable residents helping to provide
food energy furniture and costs each
year the budget for this is
approximately 300
k and very welcome there's also the
welfare rights team which are doing a
superb job in offering support around
benefit their budgeting support these
are all crucial services which i'm glad
to see continuing in this budget
but only time will tell whether this
will be able to cushion those caught in
the cost of the living cost of living
crisis
we've already seen first hand in
ultragun me out on the doors at the
weekend the effects of the increased
energy bills on residents
people coming to the door in coats
families keeping the heating off and
still accruing some substantial bills
when using the bare minimum
some are having to move homes and this
is causing anguish which i've never seen
before
their bills have tripled i found it
truly frightening
there will be support from the
government via the council but it looks
very minuscule to the stories of price
rises that we are hearing
200 pounds worth of the support next
autumn will be alone which needs to be
paid back over five years
in april we will see a 150 one-off
payment for council bans a to d and
there will be discretionary grants
for those that were worse affected
but i am
increasingly worried about the
the future that we're moving into
and
i think also
balancing this budget has been done by
using reserves in a completely
unsustainable way and these are things
that the financial director has told me
that we can't keep using reserves in
this way
on these recurring and growing costs it
is
a worrying position i think for this
council
i think um councillor welton has been
very eloquent about illustrating an area
in which the council could make extra
revenue we should look at parking in
terms of our climate emergency and about
how we can create extra revenue of
course we can't be silly and just rise
prices up
exponentially and and lower parking and
bring in less money but we should look
at it sensibly and as uh councillor
welton says you know the biggest cars
the biggest polluters maybe they should
be paying more and i would encourage the
uh council to look at this again in
terms of raising extra revenue
and how also we can change our
infrastructure and free up more space
for people that are walking cycling and
going about their daily business and
obviously we need to change our habits
but i'd also ask councillor ross how
much um revenue we've made through
evening sharp ev charging points it'd be
interesting to hear how much that is i
think it might be north but um
yeah you'd be good if you could confirm
that because that's the revenue we
should be making already
but i think
the the the the severity of the savings
that we need to make next year um should
be worrying us all in this budget
again we have been using reserves which
we can't keep doing and the council do
illustrate in this
budget that we will be going through a
change program and i have been told that
we will be looking at the non-statutory
functions of this council and every one
of them will be on the table and every
one of them will be reviewed
and
we possibly at the end of this we'll
have to make cuts that might be
uncomfortable for our residents
i did ask
how this would be conducted and whether
councillors would you know have the
right to hold to account and hopefully
this will be going through scrutiny
and councillors will be able to see the
details of this and see the possible
cuts that will be made but i just wonder
if councillor ross is being absolutely
clear with residents on the scale of the
problem that we are facing over the next
year
um
but i will congratulate this
executive
and the financial team for balancing
this budget they've done it under the
most difficult circumstances
and with a lack of government funding
which i think is
just shows how
little respect the government has for
the people of this country they don't
care about the streets they don't care
about our parks and they don't care
about the everyday environment that
people walk around is because they're
eating away that infrastructure
every day that they're in government and
i just think
as we all know they're just drunkenly
walking us into a cost of living crisis
that we may have never seen before so as
a at the green party council i am
worried about this
um
but we will be supporting this budget
thank you chair thank you councillor
jerome councillor new crush please
and you two have five minutes
of time
this evening i'll try and keep things
brief
so
many councillors tonight have spoken of
the cost of living crisis ahead of us
and i believe this is the issue of the
time
how this council approaches that with
measures to
mitigate insulate our social housing and
support our most vulnerable will be key
in the coming year and perhaps coming
years
there is much
there are many points in this budget
that
the lib dems warmly welcome
however our concern over the half
billion debt ceiling
for the investment fund has been
long-standing and it is genuine
um
and as we are not getting support this
evening to begin to reduce this
i'm not sure that we can
fully support the budget it may be that
we are going to
abstain this evening thank you
thank you councillor hugh grush
councillor evans your closing remarks
please
thank you mayor
i also take this opportunity to thank
graham bentley and his team of producing
this budget huge annual undertaking
thank you
turn to the budget my colleagues have
spoken to their specific areas and i'll
touch on a few of my own
page 24 sets out the budget approach in
november november 21 the executive
approved yet another refresh corporate
plan the new vision for trafford is
trafford where all residents communities
and businesses prosper
one of the key outcomes suggests all our
businesses and town centres will be
supported to recover and flourish for
the benefit of everyone
laudable
but it only seems to make it to paper
it's written not demonstrated with
actual actions to deliver for our
covered impacted businesses
my conservative colleagues and i have
spent many hours working to keep our
businesses afloat assisting them to
access government support provided over
the past two years through the council
support is widely recognised as world
beating
this council approached lack's vision to
support our businesses and their ability
to create jobs and prosper
businesses don't need a 60 hiking
parking charges in selected town centres
i wonder what the labour criteria was to
cherry-pick the towns for increased
charges
60 at a time when we need to be
encouraging our residents and visitors
from out of town back into our shops
anything that deters visitors is
shameful
why are simple things such as parking
charges matter
it's simple it impacts jobs growth
opportunity and ultimately revenue for
our council successful thriving
businesses pay more into the local
economy and create jobs and enhance
well-being paying more rates and renting
from our own council quoting a local
community group with the council's
anti-business approach it won't be long
before ultra um returns back to being a
ghost town
we are missing an opportunity with our
leisure center
to create a clear vision specifically
for altering him with a key gateway
development to open up altering him with
an imaginative offer
i highlight altering him as one of the
targeted areas being punished
most by labour's car parking charge
hikes the council is so uninterested in
template it gets the budget papers wrong
indicating that charges already exist
and are going up well and are going on
for elaine however due to the constant
campaigning of our team there are no
charges on foley lane
but any charges that are introduced will
be a terrible blow for the businesses of
timpani
two years ago conservatives proposed the
budget amendment that was unanimous
unanimously accepted for a hundred ev
charging points across traffic not a
single one has been delivered no attempt
to prepare for a greener future
a clear way to encourage visitors to our
towns an opportunity missed the council
seems to view our businesses as a cash
cow to be milked not an asset to be
cherished and nurtured
following huge support for jobs and
businesses from our government we should
do so much more hardly supported to
flourish and recover
moving on we have andy burnham's the
mayor of greater manchester's police
preset up by 10 pound despite being
still in special measures and reserves
of over 100 million with 70 percent of
respondents to his rushed 10-day
consultation objecting to a rise all
ignored
the direct precept for the mayor's
priorities excluding fire up nearly 300
since coming into office in 2017.
all waived through by labour with the
support of the lib dem chairman of the
scrutiny committee without one single
question being leveled at hundreds of
millions of pounds worth of spending and
yet our council here tonight will
happily accept this without objection or
even query
trafford residents deserve scrutiny and
a corporate plan match with actions that
actually support businesses
and one final thing from me the
investment management it's a pretty pity
we rejected the proposed amendment but
welcome that both the section 150 one
officer appearing to be supported by the
council leader may consider reduction of
the 500 million ceiling we would welcome
the exploration of this
we have seen a reduction in the real
terms returns despite the budgeted 7
million contribution to the budget this
area causes us continued concern
chair our group won't be supporting this
budget tonight and i would urge all
members to reject it
thank you
thank you councillor evans
councillor andrew weston has agreed at
the beginning of the meeting you now
have a maximum of 15 minutes to wind up
the debates
council of western
thank you
chair and let me begin by placing on
record as many speakers have
this evening my thanks to councillor
ross graham bentley
the finance team at the council but also
all of our staff who have been through
and we use this word far too often these
days unprecedented and extremely
challenging times
over the past two years in addition to
graham and tom i want to thank all of
our corporate leadership team a special
thank you to sarah sala who we know has
led the clt for several months this year
but also to sarah todd our chief
executive and i'm sure i speak on behalf
of us all by saying what a pleasure it
is to see her back in here this evening
it has been
an incredibly challenging time and a 20
million pound budget gap reflects that
20 million pounds
11 years into austerity having already
faced a combined budget gap of some 243
million pounds
since 2010
and in spite of that chair
we faced the ridiculous scenario this
evening
of a main opposition group
coming to this chamber with not one
proposal
for how we might close that gap
complaining
that fees and charges will increase
complaining that council tax
will go up
complaining that we're not spending
enough
on leisure centers but not making one
suggestion for what they would do indeed
increasing that funding gap
both by
telling us that they would spend more
than 20 million pounds more than we are
on leisure centers providing new that's
an additional 1.2 million pounds in
revenue each year so we jump from 20 to
21.2
and of course in supporting the liberal
democrat amendment potentially
increasing it by as much as seven point
million seven point six million pounds
more as a result of potential lost
income there and so instead of having a
20 million pound budget gap
we have a budget gap now
of
28.8 million pounds potentially as a
result of councillor evans and his
absolutely ridiculous accounting
practices they've not bothered
to bring a budget amendment chair and
there is a very simple reason for that
they have as the old adage in this
chamber used to go
no idea
no clue
and no plan
what we have instead been told having
driven that budget gap up by over 40
percent is that they oppose
council tax increases
interesting because their three-year
medium-term financial strategy on having
left office chair said that they would
take the maximum council tax increase
every year thereafter and even more
interesting when they've been in
opposition so long chair that we are
left with only bolton tories to compare
them to who are raising council tax by
more than we are this year at 3.12
i ask you when comparing records chair
would you rather have labour's lower
council tax increase in trafford and no
cuts to frontline services budget or
bolton's conservative budget not only a
higher council tax increase but a 25
cut to staff in their start well hub
you would recognize them as children's
centers and you know them well because
you like to cook them
the other addition to that of course
being the closure of a children's
nursery i know which budget i prefer but
doubtless if our conservators were in
that chamber chair they would be
supporting that budget this evening
and then we hear
having driven all of this up
that they don't
only have such ill discipline
that they fail to bring any amendment
that they failed to tell us what they
would do
that they failed to present any idea any
clue or any plan they then contradict
themselves because councillor morgan
tells us that he does not support an
increase in reserves for councillor
wetton to stand up in by far as ever the
most sensible conservative contribution
this evening and says we i do support
that and what's more you should have
gone further
councillor butt and councillor evans
then contradict councillor morgan
further because he says
in his opening comments that he supports
the leisure investment council
reverend's counselor but say they don't
and it doesn't go far enough
they really are
utterly in contempt in their actions
this evening chair it is so fiscally
irresponsible particularly
particularly when all of this is as a
direct result of the choices made by
their national government
time and again they come in here this
evening bleating about the cost of
living crisis a cost of living crisis
that they opposed emotion on at the last
council meeting a cost of living crisis
that has led to them talking about the
wonders of a 200 pound loan from the
loan shark chancellor
in order to cover the costs of rising
energy bills
a wonderful claim from councillor morgan
chair that we are going to see 350
pounds worth of help to meet the costs
of energy bills at a time when the
energy price cap is being lifted by
698 pounds you could not make it up
so where i'm at with this budget chair
is it has as ever been incredibly
challenging but i could not be more
proud
of where we have ended up and i really
welcome the mature and constructive
comments particularly of councillor
jerome but indeed of the green group
more broadly they
alone of the opposition parties in this
chamber
show some regard for the fiscal
circumstances that we find ourselves in
and i welcome that mature approach and
the dialogue that i know that they have
not only with me
but with council officers
i particularly would say that i concur
with councillor jerome's comments
about the use of reserves and he is
entirely right in saying that that is
not sustainable for us moving forward i
know that is something that councillor
ross knows i know that is something that
all of the executive certainly would
agree with and that is why we have
established the finance and change board
and that is why i've asked councillor
ross to take place on that board there
are going to be very difficult decisions
ahead but of course the use of reserves
is so significant this year because
there are several million pounds worth
of reserves used specifically to meet
the costs of covid but our finished
chair just by touching on some of the
things that i am especially proud of in
this budget in terms of
investment because yes there is the
almost 20 million pounds on schools that
councils
partly and carter referenced the 12.6
million pounds on highways and broader
infrastructure the 8 million pounds of
leisure investment that our conservative
group can't decide whether they support
or not the almost 850 k for our green
spaces and to enhance biodiversity
in trafford the 1.54 million pounds
worth of public realm investment in our
town centres when councillor evans
claims that we do nothing for our town
centres the half a million
of business loans and town centre
business loans again to those businesses
that we allegedly care nothing for
you know
you couldn't make it up they will say
anything in a desperate attempt chair
to have residents believe
that they have a better idea how to run
this council
i think it was councillor freeman that
said that residents have given a firm
view on their performance in recent
years and based on tonight i'd be
extremely surprised if residents have
finished giving them the absolute
kicking that they rightly deserve thank
you chair
thank you councillor weston
the resolutions set out on the reports
have been moved and seconded
i will now move to the vote and remind
you that statute regulations require
votes on the budget to be recorded
please can those in favor show their
hands
i've got those in yeah
thank you hands down
um and those are games please
hands down and are there any abstentions
thank you
the motion is carried everybody the
motion is carried
item four and listed on the summons is a
proposed alteration of the motion
submitted and adjourned at our last
meeting
firstly i will need to seek the consent
of the meeting to the motion being moved
with the alteration and that consent
will be sought without any discussion
does the meeting consent
i know
councillor evans please can you move the
motion as altered concerning the greater
manchester clean airplane council evans
thank you mayor
and thank you members uh for agreeing to
the changes of the original motion from
january
um
in january it finally dawned on the
residents who are traveling greater
manchester and andrew weston as lead
member and andy vernon gm mayor we're
planning a multi-million pound raid on
the businesses of greater manchester
a plan that was four years in the making
four years of informal briefings four
years of reports
four years of smoke and mirrors
throughout this time conservative
members from all boroughs were asking
questions behind the scenes
federation of small businesses was
lobbying the road haulage association
was sounding alarm bells regarding
cancelled orders for vehicles
finally following the signing of
contracts to install signs and cameras
across gm did the residents realise what
labour gm was about to impose on them 75
to that 5 000 vehicle operators were to
be hit with crippling charge
we arrived at this point without one
single question in official and
challenging scrutiny meetings informal
briefings do not
have to give official answers and warm
words suffice words such as the market
will step up
despite clear evidence to the country
a question about one fitting bay to
retrofit
75 000 vehicles can be cast aside with
vague assertions
that 75 000 turned out to be 7
500 at the last minute
that is why we are calling for a new
scrutiny panel coupled with a call for
an independent investigation only an
independent investigation will uncover
why
493 square miles were chosen why it took
90 000 facebook members to get the two
andrews to hear there are no vehicles
the retrofit scheme is a nonsense
only independent independence from a
labour dominated tfgm and gmca can
discover this
members please call support or call for
proper scrutiny and an independent
investigation thank you thank you
councillor morgan will second the motion
thank you chair um
for policies have been implanted costing
potentially billions of pounds without
having a single bit of scrutiny at
trafford council or gmca level either
isn't acceptable i don't want to rehash
the arguments from the last council
meeting and i know members across the
chain will have different um differences
on the principle of the clean air zone
and i'm not going to try and persuade
any of you to change your position on
that but i do hope everyone in this
chamber recognizes the importance of
getting the facts right before we slam
huge charge on some of our struggling
local businesses
not knowing whether it will work or not
i therefore ask you to support the
motion unaltered thank you chair
thank you
i have received notice of an amendment
to this motion
and invite the amendment to be moved by
the leader of the council please
thanks chair so
in moving the amendment we recognize the
need for there to be
greater manchester wide scrutiny
of the clean air zone moving forward
when i say that
though i do mean share a scrutiny
committee convened by the ten districts
because whilst i appreciate that it
suits councillor evans political
narrative to suggest that this is all
the doing of the mayor nothing could be
further from the truth this is in fact
a process of joint working by the ten
councils that does include incidentally
chair as councillor evans suggested that
those from all
ten boroughs of greater manchester who
were the conservative
rosette are have been asking questions
and i'd just
remind councillor evans
that bolton conservatives voted it
through their executive supported it
through their council chamber and
supported it through the combined
authority to suggest
that the conservatives locally have been
detached from this plan
is nonsense what is true is that those
who have the fortune of opposition
have been highly and consistently
opportunistic
but where it has been necessary for
conservatives to support the plan they
have done so in the same way as where it
has been necessary
for labor councils to support the plan
there's a saying chair with great power
comes great responsibility and it is
clear that the conservative group here
consistently abdicate
theirs so look
i'm in favour of a joint scrutiny
committee it wouldn't be a gmca scrutiny
committee it couldn't be a gmca scrutiny
committee what i can't agree to is an
independent investigation because i will
not be a member of that committee and
there will be 10 boroughs who will need
to make that decision so it is not in
the power of anybody
in this room to allow for
what councilor evans is asking for we
cannot stand up and say we will
commission an independent investigation
i have a view that it's not the best use
of time i have a view that actually we
should be focused on delivering the plan
that government has asked us to jointly
produce with them by july
but in any event
we could not take that decision if we
wish to what we can undertake to do is
to move forward with a proposed scrutiny
committee of the ten councils jointly
and the amendment reflects the fact that
we would be more than happy to do so
thank you chair thank you
is the amendment second in please
counter i'd said
like to take a microphone
thank you uh jeff
in second emotion i would just like to
remind members
why it's being amended there are some
things that that individual motion that
we can't accept
this is a a local scheme now as council
evans will be completely aware was that
the uh
government was taken to court by an
organization called client earth we said
this time and time again and the
government rather than deal with it
nationally which should have been the
best option
decided to pass on to local councils of
all political persuasions around the
whole country
now each area needs to develop a scheme
that's based on its own local
circumstances
now the problem is of course when you
start dealing with local schemes that
means just in a place like greater
manchester just where do you draw the
boundary for one
obviously we've contacted all the people
who are registered vehicles and go to
manchester but we cannot there is no
real way to know actually just how far
greater manchester you're going to go to
write to people to say if they work in
greater manchester there's actually no
physical way of actually knowing that
you know i mean these vehicles could be
registered fight up in lancashire they
could uh
way down cheshire merseyside you know i
mean and there's no way actually knowing
that this is why it should have really
been a national scheme to deal with it's
one of the problems we are trying to
work at we are aware of it and they're
looking at best we can but obviously the
money that we have has to be those who
are registered and working within
greater manchester and that's what we've
done within the limitations of the
scheme i used to reiterate again that at
last meeting we did put forward a motion
i actually asked the council uh to
support to actually go to the secretary
of state and ask for pause and it's
interesting that council evans and his
colleagues actually did not support that
now his government
decided to take an alternative view and
actually quite helpful they actually
agree the secretary of state actually
agreed
with andy burnham and andrew weston that
it should be poor so we can look at this
now the reason why it's been posed is
yes it's a global supply issue but what
that actually means is that the the
large organizations who buy fleet
vehicles cannot get their fleet are not
replacing them they cannot replace them
that means that the second hand and
third hand mark are not available and
therefore even if a business wants to
come along uh further down that ladder
and actually replace the vehicle they
cannot replace it and this has come out
in a report that uh councillor weston
and andy burnham actually asked for with
towards them the pandemic then last
autumn early winter and that report was
discussed in january at one of the clean
air meetings
and quite from that first time we've got
the full physical detail of that in huge
detail and i'll suggest you to read that
if if you want to analysis that there's
a similar report we'll be coming on the
situation with htvs but based on that
particular one there it's quite clear
that that we needed to pause it and uh
most people agreed that was a sensible
way forward and that's it so we can
actually look at all the issues and get
given the change in circumstances i mean
one of the issues that needs to looked
at was things like natural data
compliance there was a suggestion that
actual data compliance would be a few
years away but the pandemic and the lack
of availability i push that even further
away and that makes it more important
more than ever that we actually look at
a scheme that would work because as it
stood the scheme would not work it would
simply penalize drivers who are unable
to place a vehicle that itself wasn't
fair so we recognize that and we
actually want a scheme that actually
works and can work for the benefit but
also at the same time actually clean
all the air in greater manchester and
there are thousands of people across
greater manchester who are suffering
very badly and yet again i don't see uh
colleagues opposite actually discussing
that point in all the meetings that this
has come before this council we've
talked about this that and they were
related to it but i don't remember any
conservative
members of that actually raising the
health issues arising out between our
plan and why it's so important we
actually do that so it'd be interesting
if they could address that point i'm
sure we'd actually all welcome that
now just to quickly move on then to uh
because we covered some little points
obviously uh terms of scrutiny now i'm
quite happy uh i think we're all quite
happy to see scrutiny do it why it
hasn't happened i don't know it is a
it's also a district function so our own
scrutiny could have actually called in
that they still wished uh
they didn't choose obviously they have a
limited workload and they have so much
time to talk to each topic now i'm quite
supportive of this being done at gm
level absolutely but it is it is really
a decision by each of the districts and
uh iterate what council western said
that as much as you blame andy west
as much as you're playing the andy burns
andy burns is the one who's actually had
police to do that he is he is head of a
gmca in that sense but obviously this is
a decision of each of the 10 districts
including bolton and they all supported
this because they were directed to do so
by by your government because their
failure to actually deal with it not
once not twice but on three occasions so
we support the scrutiny and we want to
see it come out because all the detail
that's gone into this into the planning
of last few years and indeed why we need
to pause it needs to be examined and
properly examined and the evidence is
there so i'll leave it at that ever
could chair obviously say obviously if
you could support the amendment will be
really helpful thank you thank you
the amendment has been moved and
seconded
do any members wish to speak to the
amendment
councilor evans
you have the right to reply actually
councillor evans so you don't need to
put your hand up anybody else wish to
speak to the amendment
no
okay councillor evans you have the right
to reply
yeah sorry
council hoggins
the amendment
no one wants to discuss it council evans
has the right to reply to the amendment
then we'll move to a vote on the
amendment and if that's a success that
will come to us
thank you
thank you man and
cancer adds his point uh that last month
uh
we
the secretary of state agreed to a pause
what we were discussing last month um
was a pause in the funding which
actually put vehicle operators in a
worse situation uh it was recognized
that the plan was unworkable
and it's been pushed to july
and i thank the leader of the opposition
and not the opposite i'm the opposition
answer i thank the leaders
thank you thank you leader thank god
very wishful thank you now um
for at least recognizing the need for
scrutiny it's been sadly missing over
the past um four years on on all areas
of this and
the problem with the amendment is
it cuts up our motion like a kipper
removing the most vital element the call
for an independent investigation
requesting that a joint scrutiny
committee be established to initiate an
independent investigation at least a
call for that and a recognition that
that is essential our own scrutiny here
rejected the possibility to scrutinize
the plan but we are not talking about
the plan we are talking about
scrutiny of what has happened and what
will happen which is where if we'd have
had some scrutiny
years ago proper scrutiny we may not be
in this position now
labour are clearly running scared of any
scrutiny on the spend on cameras signs
and operational costs this could be
anything between 78 million and
430 million there hasn't been a forum to
ask this key question warning running
scared of the need for a
493 square mile charge across all
boroughs investigations into whether
running cycle lanes of the a56 was
subtly to increase pollution levels
where monitoring stations were situated
running scared of the electorate waking
up to the sheer cost and size of labour
and andy burnham's tax on their everyday
lives running scared throwing out in the
last few weeks one-liners such as lack
of availability and retrofitting and
poor supply chains all of which i
mentioned to this council chaired by the
deputy leader catherine hines who asked
me to stop asking questions and told me
i would have my chance an independent
investigation is the chance to stand up
for the residents of trafford greater
manchester and the recently formed
groups labor trafford embarrasses
themselves with an amendment to the
conservative motion that makes it very
clear that you will not accept any
independent scrutiny or investigation
and you ask us to accept this pitiful
offer which will only see labor
dominating scrutiny blocking any
meaningful scrutiny once again labor
marking labor's own homework
hopefully the ballot box of greater
manchester will not forgive you i know
the businesses of trafford of greater
manchester will not forget unfortunately
although it does suggest some level of
scrutiny it is certainly far from enough
thank you thank you councillor evans
i will now put the labour amendment to
the vote
all those in favor of the later
amendment please show
okay hands down
and those against the labour member
please sure
okay hands down thank you any
abstentions
thank you hands down so
the amendment is carried and the
amendment becomes a substantive motion
this evening
and do any members wish to speak
councillor coggins
thank you mayor and the uh the green
group will be voting for the motion as
amended tonight um it is uh frustrating
beyond belief to uh to see that our
illegal levels of pollution will be
allowed to continue for another two
years here in great manchester um
frustrating for for people like me and
many of us here who have campaigned for
cleaner air for our residents as quickly
as possible and but frankly chilling for
those
who actually have respiratory problems
and whose health is being further
endangered for a long period by this
um this plan was never ambitious enough
and we now have a window of time and
opportunity to make it better to step up
our ambition for a healthier happier
more prosperous greater manchester we
need to salvage what we can that is
worthwhile of this plan and also look at
what else we can do to revitalize our
city whilst cleaning our air
and the conservatives will tell us that
they want clean air but
their government isn't provided isn't
willing to provide decent hardship funds
for the small businesses affected
and the liberal democrats will say that
they want clean air but
would like free or should we say
subsidized parking increasing our
pollution cars going into our our town
centers and labor of course say that
they want clean air but there are so
many more steps our council could be
doing so many things within the remit
and the decision power of the people in
this room tonight that we could be doing
right now we could be working for a
faster roll out of cycling and walking
routes for more low traffic
neighborhoods for 20 miles speed limits
for a rapid expansion of our school
streets plan for maintaining expanding
the a56 cycle lanes whilst really
engaging with communities to
help with habit change
there's electric cargo bikes
alternatives for last mile deliveries
this vehicle sharing there are so many
things that we can and should be doing
and the fact is the fighting for our
environment is the defining issue of our
times and the health of our residents
here in trafford is our responsibility
not in 2026 but right now
it's time really that the big old
parties either get on board and embrace
this wholeheartedly or frankly move
aside and make room for some 21st
century politics with big ideas and a
vision for a better future where is the
energy and the enthusiasm and the
commitment and the passion to clean air
and a better environment that we could
be seeing that we really need a time of
crisis like this
cities like barcelona milan and paris
and oslo are prioritizing clean air
making radical changes that will bring
us healthier lives and tackle the
climate crisis
we need no more ifs and buds from the
other parties the residents in greater
manchester and trafford deserve clean
air and they deserve it now
thank you thank you councillor copkins
any other members wishing to speak
no okay i'm advised that councillor
evans again has the right to reply
you leave
i will now put the substantive motion to
the vote
all those in favor of this is everybody
understanding what we're doing your
hands are going up quickly i understand
i was in favor of the substantive motion
please show
hands down please and goes against the
substantive motion yep
okay hands down and
anybody abstaining yes two abstentions
okay thank you very much
so the substantive motion is carried the
substantive motion is carried
that is the end of the main meeting is
now to propose proposed to hold an
informal meeting of the council
to consider issuing invitations to
members of the council to be the mayor
and deputy mayor of the borough for 2022
it has been the custom in the past
merely to move second and support the
respective nominees at this stage
and reserve speeches of support until
the annual general meeting
i am aware of a nomination for the mayor
of
for the mayor of councillor chris boyes
is there a proposal please
thank you councillor evans is there a
second to please
counselor brotherton thank you
is there a supporter from the liberal
democrats please
thank you council new grosh
is there a supporter from the green
party
thank you councillor jerome
thank you i now turn to the nomination
for the deputy mayor i'm aware of a
nomination from for councillor dolores
o'sullivan
is there a proposal please
counselor acton thank you
is there a seconder please
thank you councillor evans
is there a supporter from the liberal
democrats
thank you councilman newgrosh and is
there a supporter from the green party
please thank you councillor jerome
thank you and congratulations to both
councillors chris boyes and councillors
dolores o'sullivan on their nomination
and that then is the end of the meeting
but before we go before you rush off
um the leader alluded to this a little
earlier on i'm very happy
that our chief executive is back with us
this evening
and i'd like us to give us a round of
applause
thank you for your attendance and i hope
you enjoy the rest of your evening good
night
that's
species
thank
you oh yeah
like
yes